daniel thrasher is a youtuber with over
3 million subscribers and trust me when
i tell you he is one of the most unique
people we have ever spoken to from
creating simple youtube videos out of a
passion with just his piano that
consistently went viral over and over
again to now having a full-on team
working on his million dollar empire
making masterfully produced skits on
youtube about some of the most odd
things you'll ever see it's safe to say
that daniel is one of a kind well in
this video we get an exclusive look into
daniel's extremely unique growth
strategies his unbelievable attention to
detail and some other really unique
aspects that you wouldn't believe so if
you're interested in this and you want
more content exactly like it make sure
to subscribe because we post a brand new
episode every single sunday so we'd love
to have you a part of it and now let's
start the podcast but before we go on to
that on a more serious note we gotta
thank our sponsor ftxus they've been a
serious supporter and believer of the
podcast and they've been an effort to
sponsor almost every single one of our
episodes and be a fantastic company to
work with at the exact same time and for
those aware they're one of the largest
us regulated cryptocurrency exchanges in
the world with millions of users who buy
sell track and trade both crypto and
nfts all in one place with fees that are
up to 85 percent lower than the top
competitors and i think especially with
crypto a lot of people don't understand
exactly how much money they're spending
on fees because sometimes it's just
baked into the price but on ftx us they
really do their best to bring down the
cost as much as possible to save you
more money they are soon launching ftx
stocks where you're going to be able to
trade stocks crypto and nfts all in one
platform it's really going to be an
incredible app you guys should
definitely check it out with that link
down below and just to circle back
seriously guys they've been supporting
this podcast for a very long time and it
means a lot they help us do what we do
for you guys every single sunday so if
you guys want to help us out you guys
want to help ftx out please download the
app with that link down below in the
description and again there's also a
bonus of all the way up to a hundred
dollars depending on how much you trade
so you may as well take advantage of
that it's pretty much like free money so
enjoy the link is down below in the
description and now let's get back to
the podcast welcome back to the iced
coffee hour my name is daniel thrasher
and so far this podcast has made uh 2
billion 468 million
and seventy cents 900.70 very close
farthest actually
yeah
so you get an award for that yeah well
two hundred and sixty thousand one
hundred and thirty eight dollars i think
that's what it is my real my legit guess
would have been like a million dollars
no yeah are you serious yeah it's ad
revenue
just averages just out of it yeah just
adding that doesn't include sponsors on
this no no we keep it at we've kept it
ad revenue from the very beginning so
it's consistent because that's how we
started that's fair i like that well
tomato tomato
thanks so much for coming on i really
appreciate it i've watched your videos
for
i don't know a few years now i've really
enjoyed them because you're one of the
first people
at least as far as what i'm aware
creating kind of skits around music and
taking the music element into comedy uh
at an angle that really not many people
have done before have they yeah i mean
like you know seth everman sort of
kick-started this like memeified piano
playing thing but but i didn't notice
anybody playing multiple characters
around an instrument and that's sort of
the gap i wanted to fill um like i
wanted to make sketch comedy for a long
time like i was stuck at 50k on youtube
for a while um doing really
elementary level like sketch comedy with
my friends but everybody kept commenting
like play more piano
and once i combined those two things
what i wanted to do with what they
wanted me to do that's when like
something really cool happened so tell
us your background you go to college
we're always really good at the piano
how did this happen yeah i mean i you
know when i was a kid like i whenever i
would pass a piano store which exists i
guess uh
like i would have to play every single
piano i saw because i needed to know how
they sounded and my parents saw that and
um gave me a keyboard a little casio
keyboard when i was seven um and so i've
been obsessed
ever since pretty much but self-taught
uh yeah i mean i i took piano lessons
for maybe two years um
then middle school i played in like the
jazz band which was fun my sister
begrudgingly would wake up she was in
high school and i was in middle school
and my school started before her so she
would have to groan wake up and like get
me to school before school even started
so the jazz band could practice they
always do it so early it always starts
at like seven o'clock in the morning
right at six or something now it was
insane
and you know um
shout out to jennifer for letting me do
that um but i
yeah mostly self-taught back then i also
played bagpipes competitively which was
serious
competitively competitive pipes uh
insert photo
uh yeah how does that happen um how do
you pick the bagpipes again like i want
to play that well i didn't just like one
day be like you know it'll be nice
[Laughter]
it's my middle school dunedin middle
school in in florida um dunedin florida
is like the sister city to scotland is
what they say i don't know if there's a
dunedin in scotland or if
i don't know but but we had pipes as an
option and so i played bagpipes under
mr sandy keith who was my
uh angry scottish piping instructor who
called me a ninny far too frequently
like and like the word ninny really is
an insult from wisconsin what does it
mean like idiot minnie i think so is
that offensive if you call someone and i
don't think it's anything i don't think
it's offensive in like
you know you can get canceled for it
kind of a thing but i think it's
offensive in in terms of like just when
someone sincerely calls you a ninny and
you're 14 years like it's probably not
just wait 10 years 10 years from now
we're going to look back and be like he
said the word ninny he said
yeah yeah
but acceptable now just wait yeah
and everything comes out in the watch so
you had friends that played bagpipes
parents right back as a group it was a
yeah it was like the middle school yeah
man um yeah like we all were killed and
went out you were killed of course
not enough
if i got bullied just a little bit more
i probably wouldn't be on this podcast
yeah no i i no i was i was always the
class clown but so i think i was able to
get away with a lot did you know i
played tuba no yeah that makes sense
though yes from sixth grade through i
think 11th grade i played the tuba
really you give me tuba vibes yep yeah i
picked the biggest loudest instrument i
could in middle school did you do
marching band at all no so you'd never
got around to this no no no no i i had
no interest in doing that because
i think practice started around like 6
a.m 6 30. like it was really early
but i also did the jazz band but the
jazz band was uh i think after school so
it started at like 3 30 or 4. so you
could have theoretically been there from
six o'clock
until 11 hours of school and music
yeah i enjoyed it but not enough to do
it yeah what did you what other hobbies
did you have
um at that time in your life gosh drums
really like drawings yeah i actually did
drums in the jazz band from seventh
grade through i don't know ninth grade
something like that that's sick and uh
it's hard yeah it's fun can you still do
it no
i forgot i don't know i thought you play
drums all the time though no i play
every now and then but i'm nowhere near
as good as they used to be in high
school you went from the the bagpipes
yeah into playing piano yeah i i you
know i always played piano but but i
played bagpipes and piano and at the
same time i think it was a drummer in a
church band like um
and so i was just constantly you know
wanting to jam i guess with people but
piano i started
i was always pretty good at it um and
very competitive and so i would like
whenever i would see another kid in jazz
band walk up on the piano i'd be like
let me show you and then i'll like do
something try to do something fancier
what's interesting is i i never like
okay so i ended up going to a performing
arts high school so i went to a high
school for musical theater
um
which was great and then after that i
went to scad the savannah college of art
and design for performing arts but i
started as a film major at scad because
i you know made videos
in middle school for like english
assignments and i really liked it and i
thought i wanted to be a director um but
that was way too much paperwork
apparently directors have to do a lot of
paperwork and permits and like licenses
and you know renting vans and stuff i
hate that
but now that i'm older i realize that's
like a producer's job
but
anyway it's a lot of a lot of paperwork
um so i went back into performing arts
in college and i wanted to build on top
of a skill set that i already had and by
performing arts i mean like acting and
um being
creative versus uh like piano people
think i majored in piano in college i
didn't i'm an actor first which is weird
um and uh or i have the most training in
acting um piano
just sort of was the way
like the tool
that i could use that would reach the
most eyeballs um to help me tell jokes
with what did you do right after college
right after college yeah so so you know
i majored in performing arts i was lucky
enough to be selected for the scad
showcase so they took me to la new york
and atlanta
um to like do scenes in front of
agencies and management and stuff like
that and my manager found me in la and
wanted to sign me immediately um
and
you know she represents like nathan
cress freddie from icarly oh wow yeah
and so he's in a couple of videos of
mine for that reason yeah
and so you know and i grew up watching
him and had a big crush on miranda
cosgrove and i was like i was like yeah
i want this one yeah i want
i was i was lucky enough to be offered
management in all three cities um but la
just made the most sense i'm from
florida florida boy i love palm trees
and stuff you know
so um
l.a was the move so i so i was signed in
la if i wasn't signed in la i actually
had a job lined up in korea
really i was like was going to be
one of like 13 people in the world hired
for this thing called english village so
basically
in south korea
there is a little town modeled after
like colonial virginia
where it's just a bunch of white people
because because foreigners are rare-ish
out there that all speak english and so
essentially i would be
a musical theater dora the explorer for
korean kids i'd be like what color is
that no
red red that's right yeah that would
have been my gig it was a two-year
contract um that i
almost signed you know and as an as an
actor like getting a job fresh out of
college is rare yeah you know an acting
job of any kind of any kind is rare and
i was offered like this two-year
contract like that's crazy you know so
was the pay good for for theater i mean
it was fine like i would have had
housing accommodate i think it would
have been like 30 grand a year or
something maybe i could be wrong sorry
if i'm giving away too much info i don't
even know if the company's alive anymore
but yeah i mean that plus like you know
weeks of paid vacation weeks of sick
leave like you travel all around asia
like that would have been a great gig
fresh out of college like young you know
bright-eyed actor like that would have
been great but then i got signed in la
and i was like i'm gonna do la um and it
sucked for a couple years in l.a like i
worked in coffee i worked in ice cream
shops coffee shop jobs restaurants stuff
like that
um
and i kept auditioning and i kept
getting really close to stuff and i
wouldn't get it and then i would you
know so could you tell us something you
got really close to
is there anything that we would know
yeah like he got passed up and then like
daniel radcliffe got it instead the boys
no way yeah for the lead guy
isn't that like a recent thing
uh
relatively recent i mean the the um what
is that something quade the boys on
amazon that was the thing michael reeves
made the baby video for oh no way yeah
yeah the guy who loses his girlfriend in
the first episode i had to like do that
scene at the audition but i made it to
the producer level so you had did you
cry and whatnot
tried to
yeah but yeah in the tape i did and then
yeah i think i had three auditions for
that and then no i mean i've gotten
close for a lot i mean like yeah like
i'm i'm
really close right now to something that
if i
don't get it i'll be surprised but i
can't talk about it is it big it's very
big but it would be cool if it happens
and if it doesn't happen that's cool too
i know they're watching my every move so
i'm being very vague and uh we're gonna
make you look good don't worry about it
i've i've
it's all good
please don't uh see this and
i'm not going public about it you're
still trying to to do the acting thing
like mainstreaming i mean you know
what's weird is like i don't need to
right like i like i make enough money
and i and i'm you know recognizing on
the street and stuff and like this is
going to sound really hokey um but it's
true it's real
every like birthday i've had every 11 11
i've ever
seen every like little dandelion that i
blow on or eyelash that you wish on ever
since i was 16 i watched this video
from this guy um maybe you know him he's
the he's the bald guy bright blue eyes
um i think his name is stefan james or
no no no no is that his name yeah this
is project life master project like
mastery shout out project life mastery
yeah i watched this video when i was
younger that he said like your life
should have a mission statement behind
it like you should have a mission
statement for your life distilled into
one sentence like what you really want
to do while you're alive and i and i
found it um years ago and that sentence
was in my life i want to inspire and
entertain millions of people to lead
better lives for themselves and for
others and that's it that's the sentence
and i and that's my wish at 11 11 and
all this stuff again really hokey
whatever but you know i just want to
have a good impact uh um
and so
i thought that was
that meant you know i would have to be
on a tv show
or
um
or i'd have to be dora the explorer in
korea you know or like whatever yeah but
turns out i get to do that and and based
on all the dm's i see on my instagram
and i'm sure you get the same thing
you know where i'm you're turning
people's lives around financially and
you know i'm like inspiring people to
pick up the piano or like if they have a
hard day they're watching my content
like i now no longer feel the need that
that it has to come through as an acting
job on like fx or fox you know like for
me it's
it's now like i'm living it now the the
they're just like little itches i kind
of want to scratch now so like sure if i
do get this mainstream thing um then
that sort of scratches that itch and
it will help me connect with people to
to entertain even more like it'll be
like a
a different um
expression of that and so that's great
because i sincerely want
to
keep doing what i'm doing and i think i
think spreading out and like touching
all
you know platforms like like even on a
micro scale like you know i've only been
doing youtube for so long but now i'm
like picking up numbers on tick tock and
instagram and facebook and stuff so you
know to reach over to like mainstream tv
or film um would just be another
expression of like i don't need it but i
know it'd be cool tell us about your
career on youtube and how you began to
grow that geez okay well
created it when i was 13
january 6 2007
i think is the date um 29 now so i've
been on there for a while um i was able
to quit my day job as a
coffee shop guy
on february 26 2019 so it took a long
time for me to figure out
what i was doing how it took off was i
had a video called how i accidentally
wrote the office theme song i remember
that i saw that yeah i think everybody
saw that yeah the video it's like 25
million views now right is it
something crazy yeah i don't know but
yeah that was a big thing um
and how'd you come up with that video it
was a real story it wasn't like i wasn't
meaning i wasn't like yeah no you're
just making that up no i had a chord
progression forever and it's a really
common chord progression i realize now
but back then i was 19 and i i made this
video in college and i was like i was
like i want to tell the story about how
one day i
i was playing this chord progression
that i've been playing for years every
pianist can relate to this i think you
go down you sit down at the piano and
you play the thing that you know or the
thing that you wrote just everywhere you
go it's like the first thing you sit
down and play because you're expecting
someone to be like what is that and
they'll be like oh it's something i
wrote like or whatever and so that was
the thing that i did for a long time and
then i realized it was um
the office theme song
did you realize that or just some
important i realized it um because i
heard it on the tv in the living room
and i didn't watch the office
back then
um i really didn't um
but
yeah what's funny about that is that
truly was an accident and then i did how
i accidentally or
my new series when you accidentally
write songs that already exist so now
i'm like purposefully doing it but back
then that was truly an in an accident so
when you're making a video like that do
you reverse engineer it so you hear the
song i do understand you're like oh this
would be a good song to make a video
about or just like a poppy song
yeah i mean i i i'll listen to like
toxic by britney spears and i'll be like
how do i make that sound completely
different or like how do i how can i
surprise somebody or trick someone
somebody
into
listening to this and going like oh
that's cool and be like surprised it's
this
and that's the format of the video those
videos are really fun because they're
they're
easy to do
um and they're gamified so like the the
person watching like gets to
you know guess what the next song is i
think that's a really fun like game that
can be interactive and you know yeah so
what happened after that video got a ton
of views did you realize like wait a
second i quit my job i could start doing
this now so the the
um first like office theme song thing
was
me
doing like
like that video was at 600 000 views
because it was posted on reddit and
probably got 600k views in a couple of
months that's when i was stuck at 50 000
subscribers
and um i was doing regular sketches and
at that point everybody was like just
make more piano stuff when i did my
first
video where i played multiple characters
around the instrument it was called when
you're a show-off which was based on a
true story um
where i pretended not to know how to
play the piano and then just went nuts
um that getting you know 80 000 views in
like a week or a month or something at
the time was huge
because i was only doing two or three
thousand views so what i did was i
followed the data and i replicated that
type of video and within a couple of
months i was getting
some sponsorship offers and stuff i did
an affiliate marketing deal
with this company that still to this day
pays like a thousand or two thousand
dollars a month but back then that was
as much as i made
in the coffee shop in the same video
yeah from the same from like you know
who's the who's the affiliate uh floki
floki yeah it's a it's a piano learning
software huh
it seems like a perfect affiliate it was
perfect yeah and and it's um you know
and it's been a very long relationship
with them and i still you know i do
sponsors with them still they were my
first ever they're the reason why i was
able to leave my coffee shop job but
when i did that and then suddenly i'm
making as much money on my side gig as i
am my coffee shop job i only made 1600 a
month which coffee shop was it tiago on
hollywood and la brea okay and i love
them i love them so much
the the the jumping point was i got like
a brand deal um i think it was like
three thousand dollars or four thousand
dollars for like nordvpn or audible or
something like that and um
it was my first sponsor sponsor
and when i was like oh i'm making now
double on my side job as i am
in my main job yeah that's when i had to
go to my boss and be like i think i got
to quit like i'm sorry i think i have to
go uh because then they locked in a
second sponsor a month later i was like
i'm good for the next six months
um i now have to you know and my boss
was like okay
and then i said what well what happens
if i'm terrified like what happens if i
if i don't
make it and he goes well you just come
back that's nice it's really cool yeah
and his like ability to do shout out to
santiago tiago coffee shop on the course
it's his coffee shop he's the owner
that's right and and i love that place
to death and their food is really good
and their coffee
[Applause]
what'd your parents think about this
whole thing they
my dad didn't understand it my mom you
know they didn't really
they were supportive-ish
but it wasn't until
a cousin of mine
um who did not know that he was related
to me
freaked out
um
around my dad around christmas time
my stepsisters were passing around a
phone with like a new video of mine and
my cousin was coming down the stairs and
he was like oh i know that guy that's
you know
like that's the funny piano guy and they
were like that's our brother he was like
what and my dad saw that back then i had
a hundred thousand subscribers or so
my dad saw that and was like oh
maybe my son is uh you know
well maybe something's happening it's
when yeah it's when your relatives it's
one of two things it's when they see
people freak out about you that they go
okay he's the thing
or it's when they see the money is
acting kind of similar to being a
professional musician where you have to
continually practice music to improve
your skills like what does practicing
acting look like if you have to do that
that's a great question um yeah i think
yes uh you do have to practice it it's
it's
it's a couple of things one it's being
comfortable when somebody like calls
action and you hear that
you know on the camera like and just
being able to be
all in so yeah that's a skill you have
to keep going otherwise you get like
anxious if you don't do it for a while
but i think in my job like doing sketch
comedy opposite myself gives me a huge
opportunity to keep doing that you know
and uh i have a team now that films me
and
and i watch the edits and stuff so i
feel very confident and like that i'm
still practicing you know but i do have
an acting coach as well what does that
look like to to practice something like
that
like does he give you some sort of
script and he's like okay in this scene
yeah well i mean i still audition as an
actor out here in la so like i'll
you know do
i'll get an audition every once in a
while
and i haven't been coached in a minute
because i'm very like up to speed in
terms of like
knowing how to sell a joke and stuff
just just from my own creative process
so you think that's enough practice
right now just like right now yeah
because because i
yeah i i'd say so yeah because i write
the script and i analyze it and i think
how am i going to play this and then i
do it and then off the feedback on the
audience whether video does well or not
i sort of am able to see like okay did i
do well enough or whatever like it's
just a matter of like being very
confident with the material and
understanding it deeply so like if you
get a script and you don't fully
understand it and you fake it you're a
bad actor like if there's a word in the
script like let's say let's say you have
to say the word like stop being so
obsequious and you don't know what the
word obsequious means
uh and you say it without knowing what
it means chances are you're not you're
not a strong actor you have to like
understand the intention behind what
you're saying why you're saying it what
every single word means and what you're
being told as well and do you break out
like the actual
acting skills as though you would be
doing a big production
videos or is it a different sort of like
youtube acting on the good ones i do
so so on the videos that perform the
best those are the ones that i actually
i'm working on and like i think the last
time i did like proper like actor work
on a script
was the kid who could do this is dead
now is a video that i shot in a church
did a million views it did it did well
but i think it did well because i
actually like sat down and like did
actor work on it
um
and like developed characters and stuff
um
but
no i think i'm i think i'm just like
so instinctive in the characters that
i've created and have played for so long
that i that it's much faster
and instinctive that's interesting you
know graham's actually a pretty good
actor
he can put on a face while we're filming
and he can like definitely get intense
at times i am on the other hand
give me a terrible terrible thought of
you yeah i see i like to play jokes
but uh i start laughing
dang no you start laughing if i start
laughing you're good you're gonna you
get mad at me because i'll laugh and
then you'll laugh and then we'll ruin
this yeah like even today i called jack
10 minutes before i got here i'm like
hey man we can't film here they're not
letting us in they're telling us to
leave yeah but that's the worst joke
ever because like why would aaron could
kick us out
he's
he shows up like the guest just canceled
oh man yeah you drove all the way here
they canceled see i usually believe it
at first and then i think about it like
okay that doesn't actually make sense so
your acting as good it's just the joke
itself i could i could probably improve
on that yeah yeah you just need a
writer's room yeah and so here we could
just hit you practically or something my
favorite though is to hide behind a door
and then film and then when they come
over i'll be ah
i think i've seen videos of like puppies
doing that with their owners like that's
right
yeah you're gonna be such a cool dad oh
my gosh i'll probably be terrible you
think yeah because i i love like the
scaring
no i love the scare no control no i love
the scaring aspect i put on a mask
so let's continue with the story yeah
let's in west philadelphia born and
raised
i'm sorry which story where was i where
are we talking about like uh you're
finally becoming financially stable with
this and you drop you know you quit your
job yeah i was able to quit my day job
um my boss was super cool with it and
then
i uh
then i started getting sponsors
every month every sponsor i've ever
worked with has renewed and an increase
every sponsor yeah
um
yeah for a couple years
yeah it just kept going up and up and up
and then i
got to a townhouse i was like okay well
i'm making a lot of content but at the
time
i was sharing a tiny little you know
thousand square foot apartment in
hollywood with two other people
um
and
you know rent was cheap it was 800 bucks
a month on my end but suddenly i was
making like
you know way more money um
and i was like i need i need to isolate
myself because the last sketch that i
shot in that apartment there were four
helicopters above my apartment like
ruining the sound and i was like i gotta
go like like i had my digital piano in
my bedroom my editing desk was in my
bedroom my bed was in my bedroom you
know like and so i was shooting all my
videos in my bedroom until i had like
500 000 subs 607 like it was all maybe
more but
when i left i actually got this
townhouse a three-story townhouse that i
was renting in eagle rock and it was a
really cool spot but it's very quiet and
very isolated and i moved there
intentionally because it was quiet in a
quiet neighborhood
um
in
february of 2020 wow so jeez okay i was
looking up articles before i moved to
that townhouse about isolation and
creativity
because i saw
a bo burnham special where he talked
about like you know at the top of
special he'll be like bo isolated
himself for five years uh to focus on
his comedy and i was like i think i want
to do that and there's a book called um
the talent code by daniel coyle that
talks about ray lamontagne the singer
who um pretty much locked himself up in
a house for like six months to a year
with nothing but like old ray charles
albums and otis redding albums and he
like became this crazy musician so i had
this i sort of
fantasized about
about um isolating myself and like going
crazy for youtube and so i got this
really quiet three-story townhouse in um
eagle rock and then the pandemic
happened in march of 2020
and
what was elective isolation turned into
forced isolation and so i got kind of
agoraphobic after a while but
aside from that
i had really good content for a long
time that's that's how that accidentally
series happened when you were isolating
were you like not talking to people or
were you not going outside like how did
that work i mean you know when you're in
a tiny apartment with two other people
and you walk to the grocery store and
everything's close by i walk to the
coffee shop i walk to the gym blah blah
in hollywood versus
everything is a five minute drive even
going to starbucks would be like a
five-minute drive
um
you know the grocery store was like 10
minutes away for me that was very
isolating
and
you know back then i would deliver
groceries through um
through uh amazon fresh
and stuff so i was just very you know i
was just very isolated and crazy
and uh
[Music]
when i hired my assistant
um at the time my first hire ever lee
that's when i started
chipping out of the isolation a little
bit
um
but yeah no it's pretty it's pretty wild
what was your work schedule like
my work schedule was like i would try to
write in the morning from 10 to 2 p.m
and then i would try to shoot from three
to five so i would give myself four
hours to write the script and two hours
to shoot it and then the next day i
would try to edit the whole thing in
eight hours um but those were when my
videos were a lot shorter they're a
little bit longer now but that wasn't
sustainable because because when i was
completely by myself before i got my
assistant um
i
the reason when i asked lee to join the
team it was because i was like i have
one week left in this month i have four
sponsors and four videos to make so i
had nothing done i have adhd really bad
which is why i drink cold brew all the
time i feel like it medicates me shout
out bankroll coffee
coffee.com this is from my house by the
way i brought this he didn't tell me to
bring this he was surprised yeah i saw
this i'm like wait what that's so crazy
that's so cool you brought it yeah he
sent me like a gift basket you have a
thing of all of his stuff and and uh
cool so i love this thing too because
the straw doesn't fall out yep anyway
yeah get these they're so good um even
for just for drinking water it's great
yeah
bankroll coffee.com yeah gotta always be
plugging so i was really procrastinating
and i was a horrible i was an i was a
horrible employee to myself
and then that's when i started
outsourcing um
but yeah it was it was wild what did
your first assistant do like what was
part of the job description everything
man everything he you know he he was a
writer himself lee is very talented he's
he's a writer he's a voice actor um
uh he's very funny and so he would help
me write scripts he would help me
generate ideas he would also help like
clean up the house with me um
he would help give me feedback on my
editing like you know does this joke
land does that land he was just an
all-around dude you know was he just
monday through friday like nine to five
type deal or was it more like at the
time i think it was four days a week
monday tuesday thursday friday um
because i realized i wanted wednesdays
off and saturday sunday's off but it
took a long time for me to
now i have a team of six people um seven
ish if you include um i had an intern
for a second which is cool um
but
you know and those are full-time
employees those don't count like the
people from
mythical and like my brand manager and
stuff like that so now i actually feel
like i have a work life balance but it
took me years to find a good work-life
balance i hear seven people i'm like
what do they all do yeah what do they do
yeah i can tell you okay yeah so i have
a production manager jackie she's great
what is what does she do she
so
so i'll just outline the titles so i
have a production manager an assistant
um a creative producer
two editors
a videographer okay so that's the six
that's the main six
um and so jackie my production manager
she goes through
and she she schedules everybody to do
everything and she'll check in with the
editor she'll be like where are we on
this where are we on that and she talks
to my brand manager she's like when do
you need the these deadlines by and it's
so frequent it's so many phone calls so
many and i'm horrible like ever since i
was a kid my teachers would be like he's
terrible with time management i need
somebody who's really good at it to be
you know and we flew her out from her we
found her in orlando we flew her out
from orlando she lives in l.a now she's
fantastic i would be you know
horrible like she's been such a great
addition to the team
um and she so she makes everything easy
lee my assistant
like
my like you know he does a lot of
assistant stuff but he also does a lot
of creative stuff so right now he's sort
of helping um
like i'm gonna drop merch pretty soon
i've never dropped march ever i have a
collective audience of over five million
people now and i said i've never
done a a solid merch run sure so he's
helping streamline that with like he's
helping like hire um
graphic artists for that and and there's
another side project that he's doing and
also
you know
stuff like
like um
talking to the housekeepers to go by the
house and make sure it's clean because
if it's dirty then i can't think and i'm
not you know just all kinds he's like
kind of a house manager also like we had
solar panels installed i can't keep
getting on the phone with the electric
company just stuff like that he handles
that jackie handles doing
everything employee related my creative
producer scott
helps generate ideas and he'll sometimes
write a first draft of a script and then
i'll go through and talk to him about it
and he gives notes on all the videos my
pipeline right now is don't show me
anything until it's the very best
version you think is possible
and then i will give you notes on it but
until then i don't want to hear anything
until it's done because i have like
really bad uh attention problems see but
the thing is it's like i put myself in
that position and i think if i were
responsible for writing scripts and
stuff like that i feel like i could do
like
three a day you know what i mean but
then i look at your video output and
it's like what is it at like want to win
a week yeah you know what i mean like
like are you just extremely selective
does he present you with a ton of ideas
and you just pick like one of 50 a week
or something yeah on my phone i have a
um and also my scripts are highly
scripted like set up punchline setup
punch lines you know it's it's
it's
jokes to me are like math
you know what i mean or music it has to
sound just right it has to one word too
many will ruin a joke um
and you know not that my stuff is heady
or anything but but just to like get a
good laugh out of somebody it's got to
be clean it's got to be perfect um
anyway but i have this i have a can you
show us some examples of like uh like
this is a it's a thousand video ideas
what's gonna just take yeah go ahead can
we can we read off a video idea one
random one sure okay yeah five seven
three
straightening my hair and making a
sketch about it explain the top that
quarantine has made your hair hella long
and there's nothing you could do about
it so now you want to straighten your
hair see what it looks like and make a
sketch based on the character you come
up with and i did make a sketch based on
that character his name was breiler and
that video got a couple million views
wait so why a thousand is this just like
what you built up over time yeah so so
anytime i have an idea i love this one
eight two seven when you change an
instrument and it changes your whole
personality did you do that one that's
actually really i never made that one
actually you should think so oh my gosh
that's a really good one you could do so
much with that that's it from like this
saxophone and like being really good at
math like yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
playing the two but be like oh it's an
all-you-can-eat buffet i'm gonna go
there uh guitar and like have like five
women just like pandering yeah that's
great drummer talking over everybody
yeah so the bass player alone in the
corner like dude you can do so much with
that i'm cool all right that's a great
idea i love that idea all right let's
let's pick one more all right that was
my favorite one so sure sure uh oh my
gosh you have more than a thousand yeah
and this is just mine i have a team of
people who have ideas on separate
platforms as well
like on google docs the law school amber
heard's lawyer went too
yeah that's yeah
yeah that's pretty obvious why i didn't
make that because everybody was making
that yeah yeah yeah when you suck at
setting boundaries i mean there were
there was some really
i love the instrument changing
personality yeah because i feel like you
every everybody who plays an instrument
is going to want to watch to see
what's my personality what do i do for
sure yeah i think i think for me like my
big thing with my team also like when
we're brainstorming ideas is get
get even the horrible ones write them
down
because there's a reason why you thought
of the horrible one you know like like
like just write your worst ideas down
and i bet you can't have 50 terrible
ideas in a row i bet you can't one of
them is accidentally going to be pretty
good and then build on top of that
you know i challenge you to write 50
horrible ideas back to back because one
of them is going to be amazing that's my
creative process so how's your schedule
different now than it was
how much were you working back then
versus today back then i was killing
myself yeah i was i was working until i
would forget to eat and i would be
nauseous because i forgot to eat like
it's horrible um now that i have two
editors well two and a half editors um
my videographer is a flex pa type
situation um how's the schedule
different is that what you said yeah
like how many hours are you working how
many days so we do a different thing now
like
shout out to mythical um uh
good mythical morning mythical
entertainment they invested in me and um
and helped guide me to like create a
better work-life balance
and
like part of that was hiring my
production manager and they i don't know
if this is secret sauce or not i don't
think it is but they want me to do bat
shooting so like it'll be three weeks of
prep and then one week of shooting so i
only have to
pulling out the camera gear and then
putting it away every single day was
more taxing than i thought it was i
guess um
so if we have three weeks of prep
then we can really comb through the
scripts and comb through the music and
make it perfect so that way when we
shoot we're much more efficient and then
you know we'll come out with like five
videos in that week and then i hand it
off to the editors and then they they do
that and then i have three weeks of prep
slash reviewing edits from the last
month so that's my new my new schedule
so if you film for one week and you get
five videos out of that it's like one
video per day uh yeah for that week yeah
but but
what we do is on monday we shoot all the
ads i probably have about four ads a
month so i'll shoot all my
advertisements on monday
um
and then on tuesday we have a long time
to focus on the script in the morning
and then shoot the main video wednesday
thursday friday
so it's um but your videos are like
three four minutes long so
that's like i'm very particular many
many takes each yeah i'm really really
particular about it
a two minute video is probably two and a
half hours of footage really yeah see
for me i would film for probably about
an hour and a half two hours for a 15
minute video that's insane
but maybe maybe i'm just not as picky or
do you
like do you ever mispronounce words or
no no no it's it's just a matter of like
like okay i j well because it's all me
right i'm not interacting with somebody
else it's all me going like okay how did
i say that and and like
because if cause let's say i do it take
seven seven different ways the following
take of the different of the next
character has to make sense it has to
seem i'm very proud that my my videos
seem conversational i get a lot of
comments that say like i forget that
it's the same guy yeah and the reason
for that is because i try to map out the
funniest way to present something from
this direction and then how would how
would a human actually respond
visually
you know like like listening to someone
say something like you need a listening
take you need like a
you know i call it i call it a what take
i always have a what taken a video like
what like you know if somebody says
something ridiculous and you gotta catch
it
and and also you got to figure out where
they're standing in relation to the
camera and all this stuff it's like it's
very like
in-depth to make it believable the
number one thing i tell my editors when
they're going through is like bare
minimum like the script does all the
heavy lifting of the of the jokes but in
the performance
minimum
it needs to be believable
and it needs to be intelligible can you
hear what i'm saying can you hear the
setup to the joke can you hear the
punchline of the joke and is does it
seem like two people are actually having
a conversation outside of that the
script does all that so i take it you
just sit in the same spot or stand in
the same spot go through all of those
scenes in that one take and then move to
the different one and then enter so each
character is about a 30 minute take so
daniel sitting at the piano daniel's my
like straight man character wears this
black v-neck usually
sitting at the piano uh
that'll take 30 minutes or it'll take an
hour and a half if i have to play piano
because then i'm also really particular
about how i sound on the keys
piano videos always take much longer um
but they get more views generally not
anymore but anyway um but yeah it takes
a long time so i'll do i'll do one
rolling take for half an hour where i'll
just go through the first line i'll
scrub through that five times i'll go
through the next line about five times
i'll go through the next
next line and i just methodically go
through the whole thing it's probably
um
my editor might just be pulling the
first take of each and then i go back
and be like there's a better take in
there so so maybe there's a better way
for me to do that but
you know what would probably be easier
for me is if i actually look at the
script because like i just write it
until it's done and then i shoot it
um
what would be easier is if i actually if
i did actor work like actor prep work
and sat down and circled lines and wrote
about it and stuff then it would be a
much more um efficient shooting time but
now that i bought a red camera
which is
oodles and oodles of data like like
terabytes of data for minutes of footage
essentially um i i should be more
particular about doing prep work so that
way we don't waste rolling time yeah
here i am thinking like oh these are
such easy videos to make three minutes
why do you need so many people i would
just sit there and like bang out a video
a day like so easily i probably could i
probably could um if i were
and i probably should
but
but i'm so you know i really like where
i'm heading now i think the the
direction that i'm going is strong and i
think people can tell that i'm
like like for example i made a video
spoofing hamilton and like that video
it's called how lin-manuel miranda
orders a pizza that was the first video
i shot on a red and like i rented out a
theater i hired four other actors i
choreographed them just to help me
do an imitation of lin-manuel miranda
ordering a pizza on the phone
um and and i like taking stupidity so
seriously i think it's great i will say
i didn't know who that was right that
deterred me from watching the video okay
that's cool but part of it was like like
i saw the title i'm like i don't know
who lin-manuel
is yeah but it's also kind of funny that
i don't know who he is but it's like
such a he's the guy who wrote hamilton
okay yeah yeah i don't know so
hamilton's like huge you know it's a big
broadway thing anyway
but uh but those who do like saw it and
we're like what the hell like you know
uh
but i i really like where i'm going and
so i bought i bought the red camera
because i wanted to be able to have like
a
like a weapon if i needed it you know i
think of everything as a tool to tell
jokes with you know you know on
spongebob where
like like it's just the regular
animation and then suddenly they have a
stream close up of squidwards you know
it was like so detailed yeah like the
handsome squidward yeah and that's kind
of what yeah yeah and that's kind of why
i got the red that would be funny it's
because like it's cuz like you know
sometimes to punctuate a joke to just
make it look like real life was like
whoa now i'm uncomfortable now i'm like
looking at it from a different angle
you know i just want to have like a tool
belt just a big old tool belt to tell
jokes how much was that camera
40
thousand dollars
a car
yeah
yeah i bought it did you not get like 98
of the same thing with a three thousand
dollar camera yeah i mean my canon r5 is
like an amazing camera
shoots an 8k also um
the average person can't tell the
difference but if i want to be able to
submit to like netflix one day like
i want to be able to have that in-house
my dream is to just rent like a house in
the middle of nowhere take my whole team
with me
maybe a makeup person a sound person and
a lighting person and
do something that's an hour long
and just make it crazy like like what's
up with me in isolation
but but i really want to like
just make something with that red camera
and just sell it somewhere just put it
on like hbo or like you know i i'm so
like excited by the idea that i can make
something that could theoretically play
in imax because the camera is so
ridiculous you know
that's just really exciting to me it's
inspiring i think you know if you get
gear that like inspires you to think
outside the box and like do something
that pushes you that's cool but if
you're if you're getting gear because
everybody else has it like these like
tech youtubers who like all have the
same like neon backdrop and the same
like you know
like stick around or like
the same dinosaur skull let's jump right
into it
you know like what's up you guys like
who says smash that like button like
what a loser
though
but but um but no i i
yeah i'm i'm i'm really stoked with like
this like sort of machine that i'm
building now um and like and that's why
i'm also excited about i just finally
got approved for monetization on
facebook which is so sick and i think of
i think of money now as like
who can i hire with this to help me
tell better jokes and to like help me
make better content um
uh because the goal again at the end of
the day is to like make people feel a
little a bit easier and also i get to
drive a mercedes so that's nice
that's your daily driver mercedes yeah
what kind e450 coupe
i like it a lot how did good mythical
morning happen you know link reached out
to me on twitter um
i guess his daughter is a big fan and
she's so she showed him one of my videos
and
he did it he's like hey let's have a
meeting and i was like okay sure you
know i thought he wanted me to like
guest star on like an episode of good
mythical morning because they just did
that with my friend charles cornell
who's a jazz pianist he's very funny
i was like oh cool i think i might be on
good mythical morning
but that's not what the meeting was it
was him and rhett sitting on zoom
opposite me and my assistant lee
and
link goes
what do you want to do
and i was like you mean like in a video
or like
it's like no just
with your career what do you want and i
was like
oh
you know i was like well i
i sort of am modeling my career after
this person and that person and i want
to do this and i want to do that thing
and i'm working on this and blah blah
blah
and goes
great
you know and then he this was a year and
a half ago this is a long time ago
um and they developed this like
creator accelerator program i'm only one
of two
people
uh who are in it and i'm fairly sure i
was the first guy
they came to um
but it's like this
really awesome mentorship thing
where they're
just showing me like what works for them
and they're
guiding me in the right direction to
like
they basically said like
you know it seems like you don't have a
strong work-life balance right now i was
like i don't
and they're like we know how they're
engineers they went to engineering
school together so they sort of created
this machine of content creation
that's automated
and
still very good to where they're able to
have a life
you know
and i think the thing about being a
youtuber
is it is very stressful and you will
burn out if you're not careful like if
you're not outsourcing at all and you
think you have to do everything yourself
you're gonna burn out um for sure it's
just a matter of time
and so now that i have a team of six to
help like catch the net it's it's great
it's so much better now so how does it
work with them do they own a percentage
of the channel yeah okay
so they own a percentage
um in exchange for like
cash
and then i use that cash
in specific ways hiring people giving my
current employees arrays is part of that
which is great they encouraged me to
give my employees raises
not that i was against it it was just
like
it was just i was highly against it it
was just it was just i didn't know the
rate like i didn't know the going rate
and they helped me schedule and give
people proper titles and like
incorporate well and and like you know
tax stuff and all this and like was that
like them or was that some part of their
team or someone on their team that was
helping you through that process it was
it was
um
so they have a rep who i talk to
um every week and then i talk to them
at least quarterly and i'll have like
lunches with them and stuff so
everybody knows what everybody else is
doing
and uh it's amazing it's really great
and and so they sort of like and their
rep talks to them as well as the the you
know producers with mythical to be like
what do you think about this what do you
think you know and so i get the whole
sounding board of like this 100 plus
team
who's been doing this for years um
to help me hire somebody like to help me
like figure out what's the going rate
for this what's the you know what should
i call this person like
um how do i do this basically we're
getting to a place to where i can just
go i want you know a book
i want to write a book
and then they'll go okay this is what
you do
you know
go ahead and write it and then we'll
send it over here
like sweet
it's great it's really nice uh i want
merch and then and then they'll go out
and try several different um merch
providers or whatever you call that
merchandisers
[Laughter]
you know it's great it's really nice um
because i'd been doing it by myself for
so long now i actually feel like
i can um
relax a little bit i'm approaching 30.
like one day i would like to have a
family and like and like and like in
every other relationship i've ever had
it's always been a problem
that i'm working all the time like like
on thanksgiving day even even familial
relationships like like if i on
thanksgiving day for the past like
several thanksgivings i've been editing
on thanksgiving thinking like if i make
just this right video about this turkey
like then i'll get a million views and
everyone will love me and like that's
not you know it's a we're crazy like
don't date a youtuber please like you
know don't unless they have a team uh
you know like like graham and i are fine
but um
don't you know don't don't go for either
of us but
you know it's insane like like it's it's
crazy but i'm very grateful that now i
can relax a little bit i think i
answered a question i don't know if i
did or not i think that way i think that
was the question now what happens if you
went for them and then a month later
you're like that's not working out or
like six months in and you want to back
out of the deal is was there a clause in
there that allowed you to do that if it
wasn't a good fit for you i don't know
what i'm allowed to talk about yeah i do
know that i felt very safe to take the
risk um um
and there was like some protective
provisions to where it was only a
win-win which is great can we talk a
little bit about finances sure let's
talk about laney
i notice
at the end of almost every single one of
your videos you have a sponsor yeah
right that's like that's like what 85
percent of your video is 90 at this
point probably 99. that's impressive
yeah in the past two or three years only
two videos have not been sponsored so
you must be you know
pulling in a little bit i'm doing all
right
yeah i'm doing i'm doing pretty good i'm
very fortunate and and i found a way to
have a sponsor in every video without it
being annoying
yeah you have the skit after skit yeah
the the and now for the sketch after the
sketch that happens to be paid for yeah
and and like i only have you know my
videos are only three minutes long
so chances are most people are going to
be there at least at the start of the ad
you know that's true and so um
yeah and brands have been really really
responsive to that and they they
they like that a lot and i like that
they like that yeah how much of that are
you saving well now that my overhead is
so much i mean
i don't know
uh my overhead's pretty high now
um
i think just to maintain everything
like my house and my employees and stuff
is probably like 30 grand a month just
to just to operate
um and stay afloat so i have to do more
than that a month to profit
sure and then um
so and then also i i buy stupid stuff a
lot um not i mean i mean now i do
okay it took me a while but now i'm like
these shoes are a thousand dollars wait
no are you serious you're kidding me did
you actually buy it i've only done that
twice in my whole life what shoes the
montclair shoes and i bought them for a
red carpet event so they're attacks
right off um
okay you have a dinosaur skull in your
head it's a replica it's a replica and i
bought it i bought it the first one i
bought from wayfair and then i found a
cheaper version i think at walmart
seriously
so i did a reverse image search
wayfair stopped selling that exact
dinosaur skull and sold something
slightly different so i reversed image
search the first dinosaur skull and went
back through my email found it and then
found that i think it was walmart that
sold the exact same thing but it was
even cheaper yeah so they all outsourced
from the same spot you know what i will
say though like this whole this whole
idea of like spending to like
present yourself a certain way or
whatever i i will say this is like a
real thing like the like me driving my
car my mercedes right um it's a lease it
probably costs you know fifteen hundred
dollars a month with with insurance and
the lease oh my god well i mean i mean
combined you know
probably maybe less maybe less okay i
think it is less i think it's 13 or
something or 12. um anyway
but
like
the whole thing about like
driving to an audition or driving to
meet an executive
it it i think in a subliminal way it
would instill just a little bit more
confidence being like that guy seems
confident and like powerful and like you
know it i know that's so shallow but i
live in l.a you know what i mean like
it really is like if you live in any
other town like like florida nobody
cares dude you know like like but in la
if you're meeting with like an executive
of like a major network and you show up
in like a 2001 honda civic where it
leaks when it rains my old car like
right before i got this one you know
then they're gonna be like i don't know
can we like
trust this guy like it's very silly it's
very silly but
but you do have to play those like yeah
i noticed that as a real estate agent
yeah i was driving a prius for the
longest time yeah and
uh in the beginning jason oppenheim
would let me drive his aston martin and
he had to vanquish
and so if he wasn't driving 200 000 cars
they're handmade aren't they the msrp of
that car i think was like 350.
something crazy like that but yeah half
the day he wasn't driving the car and so
if i had a showing i would just take his
car and i noticed a huge difference when
i pull up in that car versus the prius
yeah man could be the same client but
when you show up to a really expensive
house all of a sudden people took me a
lot more seriously that's real yeah when
i was buying houses when i when i was
looking for the house that i bought yeah
like not buying multiple houses
like when i was shopping for houses i
noticed that
you know well i mean i hadn't had the
alternate alternative in my old honda
but like if i pull up in a mercedes like
and i walk out they're going to show me
the house they're going to like walk
with me and look around and treat me
like a serious dude because i'm a i'm a
goofy guy who looks like i'm 20
something oh well i am 20 something
like you know i look i look like a
scrawny kid
you know who's just geeking around and
uh but if they see me pull up in this
thing then they're like okay let me give
you my card let's talk about it you know
let's um
i will tell you how many offers we got
on this thing i will tell you you know
it's a weird game like it's weird
um that's true yeah could you tell us
about the house you bought i don't know
if you want to discuss that yeah i
bought a house from
a guy who was in very famous commercials
and uh i bought his house that was
really cool
did you know it was his house going into
it yeah
did that make you want to buy it yeah
because what's interesting is like
advertiser money bought that house for
him and advertiser money bought that
house for me and what's really funny
about it is like after it's isaiah
mustafa it's the guy who like was the
old spice guy who's like look at your
man now back to me now back in jamaica
back to me i bought his house from him
like which is so sick and like in the
guest bathroom
um his he or
uh somebody left behind two old spice
body washes underneath the sink and so i
have them on display in that bathroom
now but his house is sexy like it's so
cool it's a really neat house i barely
had to do anything with it and like
it's such a beautiful house and i'm so
grateful um but like it's a fun story
too like it's just cool to have like
this
guy's house like you ever meet him or no
no but he follows me on instagram which
is cool why didn't you get to meet him
you would think that usually once the
all contingencies are removed you go
through a final walkthrough and the
seller's there to like greet you he's
just busy really and also he didn't know
who i was at the time like like if i you
know i i would not want to sell anything
to a geeky youtuber like in no way like
you know he sees your offers like now
not that if i was like an emmy award
winning actor like no i you know but
he's like a big he's a big movie star
now where did he move to do you know i
don't know some place where he could
have land i think he has like horses now
or something i'm not sure
wasn't there an ad of him as a horse
though oh no on a horse on a horse so
now he's i remember that yeah that is
something i do remember i'm on a horse
yeah your tickets are now diamonds yeah
that's so cool man because that's a
funny ad and like and like that was
inspiration for me to start making my
sketches my sketches after the sketch
like funny ads that aren't just an ad
read on a teleprompter it's more so like
you know i'm like how do i make this
interesting and my brother and i uh my
brother dylan and i when we were kids we
would play this game called sell this or
whatever and so we would pull out like a
coke and we would we would make like
goofy jokes about coca-cola and try to
figure out like how would we sell this
to people and so now i do that for a
living that's how i make a majority of
my money that's really cool how long do
you expect to keep this house for i want
to keep it as long as i can i want to
use it as a rental
if i book this thing that i'm currently
running for i'll be away from the house
for a while um but i have employees so
you can't rob me haha but like i i
i would keep it and maybe rent it out as
an airbnb or or
do um
long long term rental because i want to
hold on to it i really love
where it is and
uh just what it is got it i got a random
offbeat question but why don't you or
why didn't you stretch out your videos
to eight minutes to throw in middle mid
roll ads because all of your videos are
very very short comedy is all about
trimming the fat
if you add too much fat like snl
sketches the ones that aren't funny are
because they went on too long
you know and i'd rather i'd rather tell
stronger punchier jokes like even three
minutes for me is pushing it you know
it's hard to keep somebody's attention
especially with tick tock now yeah they
get the funniest thing in less than 60
seconds that's why
i on the videos where i do go past eight
minutes i do get double ad rev but but a
lion's share of my income most of my
income is from sponsors so it doesn't
really matter as much
can you
allocate some percentages to where your
income's coming from
i would say
uh i would say 75 percent of my income
is from sponsors
and 2025 25 is ad revenue yeah and you
have no other sources of income no
i mean because on youtube because i
don't do merch yeah i'm going to
but that's where mythical comes in
they're they're helping me turn on all
the faucets in last week i just got
monetized on facebook and just in a week
on facebook i'm already paying for one
of my employees full-time incredible
just in one week you know why because
your videos are so short
and they apply to anybody
i remember for the first six months i
started posting videos on facebook and i
was paying a company out of pocket to
post these videos and take what's
already on the channel but condense it
down add subtitles so they take a 10
minute video take it down to like five
six minutes
and it bombed the finance videos because
it's it's only us-based uh english
speaking and a very narrow focus on
facebook
where facebook content tends to be
global yeah so your content is perf way
better than mine is for facebook i'm
excited i'm really excited about it and
i and i um hope to continue growing on
facebook i've heard from several
creators saying that facebook ad revenue
is higher than than youtube ad rev so if
i can do that then suddenly i'm paying
for all my employees just within
facebook and then merch comes in and
then you know if i do a book or whatever
tour again
then all of that sort of will pay for
like cooler projects i could rent out
locations and like get a crew can you
talk to us about your thoughts on
potentially maybe doing creator clash
yes
i i
may or may not be involved in that
um
but there's a lot of things on my plate
right now to where i don't know if i am
even able to um but i thought about it
and i do did do boxing uh lessons for a
bit um
but
uh my when i toured just now my shoulder
tore up just from me carrying around a
keyboard so it's probably not the best
move that's convenient which is so i
know i know but
we talked about it when you came over to
my house
i told you to do it but you had to be
dedicated to it yeah and like
we'll see i don't know if i if i end up
doing it cool if i don't
also cool like but it would be
it would be fun and also it's in my
hometown it's in florida like
like i was supposed to be there um to
watch your fight um
at the youngling center right and i'm
from saint pete florida which is right
next to tampa and um
you know and i hung out with uh moist
critical just a couple weeks before that
happened anyway but i was i was asked to
to host the commencement address at my
college um that same week
okay but that was so cool like that was
cool i got to introduce amy poehler like
that's sick that's cool
cool bro
i can't wait for the next creator class
though that'll be cool i'll be there
like i would i'd watch it at least
depending on where i am in the world
i bet he'll be able to uh surpass the
first one it's really hard to like make
it better than the first but i think he
could do it because the first one people
didn't know what to expect that's what
it is yeah yeah but now the second one
is gonna be like
he's gotta hit that second one i i'm
sure yeah i think a lot of big creators
saw the first one they're like wow that
was a success i want to do it so we can
have access to talent for sure for sure
yeah
shout out to him he yeah raised a lot of
money for charity that's great he'll be
able to grow this into something huge
imagine this he could take it now every
year yeah and do a creator clash but
take it bigger and bigger and bigger and
like you know go to fifteen thousand
people stadium twenty thousand arenas
yeah and he'll be able to get better in
each each one a million percent you know
and and uh and it's a it was already a
proven concept this whole idea of like
celebrity death match right like it's
it's already been proven
so he just took it he's like this is an
idea
let me use this for good and then yeah
but the crazy thing is that um you know
the logan paul won the jake paul had
been successful but then afterwards that
what was the ace uh the is family one
just seemed to god
it was so bad but they made no no
mcbroom oh is he an ace family yeah yeah
that's his family i forget what it was
where he fought bryce hall and i think
no
yeah but there was a lot of skepticism i
feel like after that where ian had to
overcome those obstacles of just like
that was the last perception people had
a box and was like oh yeah bryce hall
austin mcbroom nobody watched everyone
just watched there's a difference
between like youtubers and tick talkers
though i think like bryce hall is mainly
at tick tocker right yes but you're like
pretty big yeah but i feel like
youtubers have like a stronger
connection with their audience i don't
know
or there's something about it and also
like bryce hall like probably appeals to
a lot of like children right like
like i don't know oh he's gonna call you
out man
whatever he's gonna box you call me out
dog whatever like
anyway
i don't know
children i don't know it's like kids
right you know let's talk a little bit
about the tour sure so you went and
played live in front of audiences yeah i
did a
it's a really crazy interactive show
that i do with a projector and it's very
planned out and i interact with the
projector and it's very like you know
it's written like a play and it's an
hour 15 and there's allotted time for me
to improvise with the audience and do
fun stuff like i have clips on instagram
doing millions of views because from me
getting random words and making up songs
about those random words like
it's sick i love it so much and i only
did a five city
leg but i'm gonna i would like to do it
again
um it was insane what are the economics
behind it isn't that a really high
overhead it's it is yeah it's really
high right and i and i went into it
thinking i was gonna lose money yeah i
went into it being told that i would be
in the red
um but i came out
i doubled every uh expectation they had
um which is great because i would rather
not be in the red but it was uh
it was very
um
i did not do tour for the money i did it
because i wanted to meet people and i
wanted to like practice like being funny
in front of an audience um to like
sharpen the sword you know because like
if you're in that bubble of the internet
you're reading comments you don't know
but hearing an audible laugh after a
joke tells me okay my instincts here
i can use that in the next video and i
can use this and that
and uh it just made me a better
comedian i guess um but when i do it
again
it's a lot of overhead but now i know
now i have the data to be like okay i
sell to about this size house
and uh how many people were showing up
there's about 300 a venue something like
that wow um
uh
ish 3 2 300 but it everything was like
80 85 90 sold out which is good because
there was cancellations because i had
coved and then you know people would
refund and then new people would come in
but it ended up being okay but now that
i have like more of an audience on
facebook and instagram the challenge is
like what really sucks is people will
watch my videos and go i didn't even
know you were there because like it's
hard i hate promoting you have to you
know you have to for live stuff and like
next goal around i would rather like
really focus on targeted facebook ads
for people who are likely to know who i
am because they don't even like fans who
have known me for years like they're not
going to watch every video so chances
are they're not going to watch the one
video where i talk about going on tour
and and then they're going to miss it
and it's in their hometown you know like
so that's the big challenge that i have
with with touring is like danny duncan
seems to put it at the very end of his
videos as like a like a card where it
says like tour dates and he puts all the
dates in the cities on the end of every
one of his videos when he's going on
tour that's smart yeah see that's what i
that's i kind of had something
similar-ish but i think i need to i'll
get better about that too especially for
tick-tock and and uh
instagram reels maybe yeah are you
pretty strict on yourself with regards
to retention so for example if you threw
that in at the end of the video would
you worry that that could somehow lower
the retention and hurt performance it
would be three seconds or less
um i am strict on it um
but yeah it would be really quick
or you could make it a possible moment
where just go
and
it's the card and then leave it alone
so that way maybe there's an uptick in
retention for people who want to go back
and gamify it and pause it
that's probably what i would end up
doing next time be funny to put in a
free ticket somewhere in every video but
they have to find it it just flashes on
screen so people have to find it and
then pause it
or they have to watch it like point two
five speed yeah it's on there for like
an eighth of a second and they have to
find it that's brilliant i might do that
i would try to see what happens one free
ticket per video that's so cool yeah
and you could always pin a uh comment at
the very top yeah yeah reiterate hey
it's a ticket in here yeah gotta
screenshot it type in a code and then
hitting comments are so good yeah for
call to action for like follow me on
instagram follow me on
i love penn comments man
yeah best now why put so much emphasis
on like tv or netflix versus just doing
what you're doing on youtube because you
could do you could get probably just as
many views on youtube full control over
it make all the money not get the
rights away on all platforms i'm doing
at least 30 million views a month um
uh
so and that's better than a lot of shows
you know yeah um so
honestly just to meet the right people
to enable me to tell late better stories
later
because i i look young right now and
that's great for the internet but maybe
i won't
10 15 years from now and i don't know
how appealing that's going to be to the
people on youtube instagram tick tock i
would like to make a movie um myself so
i guess like me starring in a show or a
movie would be me entering on the ground
floor which is so
backwards
but that would be my way of like meeting
the right people shaking the right hands
learning how to be a show runner
learning what what it takes to create a
successful work environment and also who
to hire like gaffers and like dps and
stuff
to be able to create something fantastic
i really love how donald glover
um aka childish gambino used to have the
number one sketch comedy channel on
youtube a lot of people don't know that
he had a comedy channel called derek
comedy which had like 160 000
subs back then
um
he was above smosh you know for a while
and and uh then he was able to leverage
that and get a writing job um
you know on um 30 rock and then he like
became a star on community and now he
created his own show on fx atlanta that
was a smash hit but his trajectory was
you know he he shook the right hands and
he knew the right people to where he was
able to make something substantial and
and respected and critically claimed and
so like
it's not and and me wanting to do that
is not a matter of me just wanting to
make something critically clamped
honestly i want to just hire more
artists like i want to hire more
actors and more people more more uh
writers and people who are good at what
they do but don't know how to monetize
it like i want to find those people and
give them jobs
um
that's kind of why i want to i want to
scale up versus like you know doing it
all myself i could technically edit and
write everything myself but i like the
idea of like
you know a guy who would be working
as a
like my creative producer his last job
was doing the census like knocking on
doors
yeah he's from harvard so he probably
felt like he was doing a service to the
world and i'm sure he was but but like
you know now he gets to write jokes and
i had one of those census people come up
to the house so many times that's
probably him yeah that's probably scott
i forget if i would just not be
interested but then they would just come
back over and over and over and over
your name on the paper no it's like a
survey that you fill out they want
everyone to fill it out it's how the
government like figures out how many
people are living in areas and stuff and
what their income is and just getting
demographics
what's one thing you think you could do
better with your current business i
think i need to be more involved i
always feel this way but i think i i
which is so ironic because i just talked
about outsourcing everything but but i
think like
there's one thing i could do better well
definitely like now that i'm improving
my gear i think i think i need to start
really looking into like a lot of my
team i sort of trained up from the from
a base knowledge i think the next time i
hire somebody it's going to be somebody
who has way more knowledge about
something than i do like like a like a
director of photography like a good dp
like who knows how to light a scene you
know
um versus me
buying the lighting gear and being like
what if i bounce it off the roof you
know
that's something i could be better at is
outsourcing to people who are really
strong
um
uh
at things so they pull you up so they
pull me up rather than me training
people if that makes sense in merch i'm
figuring out merch
uh that's something i haven't really
accessed yet but i'm working on it um
but in terms of content
yeah i don't know man probably title
thumbnail game probably mm-hmm because
like on twitter a bit blurry i've
noticed do you think yeah blurry
interesting
um
lin manuel a little niche i think well
maybe not maybe maybe he's extremely
famous the thing is that video on tick
tock
two million views that video on youtube
500 000.
so definitely what's limiting me on
youtube right now is my is my title do
you need to know who lin manuel is to
make it funny or no you tell me
i think i don't know i'll watch it i
think you need to watch it it's so
stupid and ridiculous got it okay um
that i'm really curious actually okay
i'll let you know
yeah yeah it's very silly but but i'm
excited to keep like
you know making really stupid big
content for no reason at all generally i
found that the more generic you are and
broad-based the better the videos you're
gonna do like the instrument personality
thing yeah every anyone who's ever
played an instrument would watch that
video interesting i always try to think
it
at least for my titles
every word you put in distills the
audience just like a little bit
so the the more i could convey with
fewer words the better fascinating yeah
like let's just say like investing
for beginners now everyone who's not a
beginner is not going to watch the video
investing for beginners how to
start a roth ira right now you've
distilled it even more now it's like oh
beginners who want to invest in roth it
so i really try to do limiting your
products audience possible that's
interesting
i find that when you go really specific
like like i did a video called when you
make a tritone in medieval times when
you hit a tritone in medieval times
that's a very specific
joke yes but it's but but everyone knows
the medieval times yeah so i still
like not everybody knows what a tritone
is so like that video did like seven
million views or something like that but
i made a good title i made a super
general video called how to play piano
and i thought and everybody on my
comments has been asking me how to play
piano didn't even hit a million no
so i could long tail though that's
probably going to do really well over a
year that's probably yeah that's
probably right so so that's you know i
don't know it's weird game youtube's
algorithm
i don't know if it's an algorithm
algorithm thing or you know i'm sure
it's my bad and how i'm packaging it but
i think um tick tock does such a better
job at just like shotguning content to
everybody and if it's good it gets
rewarded on tick tock much more easily
than like i'll know a video wasn't good
if it does 400 000 views on youtube and
400 000 views on tick tock that's when
i'm like okay that's where it lives you
know yeah but if a video did 400 000
views on youtube but
15 million on tick tock then i'm like
it's a packaging problem yeah i know
sometimes i've had videos do well on one
but not the other like some do really
well on youtube bomb on tick tock and
vice versa yeah i cannot find any
correlation that says one will do better
than the other that's why it's so
important to to be on
facebook and tick tock and instagram and
snapchat and you know youtube because
too many platforms i know i think
eventually it's going to all condense
down to one but the fed has disney
disney plus plus yeah but if you but if
you do like a disney square disney
square
that's really funny someone will do that
they'll steal it but like the idea that
you can quadruple dip content right now
and earn 4x the ad revenue on it that's
something that i'm really excited to
like get into so that way i can employ
more people and make better this should
be a a platform that aggregates all
these social medias together in one oh
oh
they would type in like
daniel thrasher and it shows like your
instagram posts snapchat just like so it
just shotguns it to all these different
platforms no just so you're you're
talking about it on the receiving end
yeah so i'd be able to search as a user
one person but get all of their content
in one page wow because there's so many
different platforms it would be cool to
just drag a video and title it in
description
and it just puts it on every single
platform that would be sick they have
that already for the podcast so we use
anchor the streaming service and it
already puts it on google podcast apple
podcast it does everything and i upload
it to one thing but it'd be cool with
like actual video content yeah
we just came up with something that's a
great idea i hope i'm not being boring
by the way i feel i feel like this is
great i feel like i'm i feel like i'm so
like insane on the internet and now i'm
sitting down here i'm like can i drive a
car
this is great i love it
tell us a joke
be funny make us laugh okay you ready
for this one it's a knock knock joke you
start ready knock knock
i'm not gonna answer the door
you gonna get who's there
who's there
what
knock knock who's there
this joke is that's just for the
audience
it's not it's not a good one
am i not getting the joke
it's not a good one yeah this joke yeah
let's move on
to joke over the joke's over that was a
joke i just started weeping and like
all right that was our podcast everybody
just like failed
it wasn't meant to be funny anything you
want to bring up anything you want to
talk about like any topics that you feel
we didn't cover anything you want to
mention
world peace what's your biggest
insecurity
what is my biggest insecurity i feel
more secure now than ever um that's a
great question i've never been asked
that question before outside of romantic
partners
um i feel so secure right now
because i have because i have a team i
guess i guess my biggest desire i guess
is to be respected by my peers
you know sincerely respected by my peers
because there was a period of time there
where
i felt like comedy people thought i was
using music as a crutch and music people
thought i was using comedy as a crutch
so like i was like weaseling my way and
you know and so my biggest desire like
my hope is to be respected by people
that i also respect and i think i'm
getting there but i'm not quite there so
maybe that's my
my soft spot you know if somebody that i
really like was like yeah the video did
well but i don't think you're funny you
know or whatever like like i don't want
to be labeled as like an instagram
comedian type guy who's like boiling you
know like looking at like butts and
stuff like that's so
you know i really hope people don't
think that because whenever i meet
people they assume that my demo is like
children and i'm like why you know why
do you think that do you not like you
know do you know what i mean so like
maybe that's maybe that's a little bit
of an insecurity but i you know i hope
to
keep evolving and like get better at
that that's cool so that's that's yeah
i'm very i'm in a very like lucky great
i'm very very grateful and i and i hope
to do this
at least be an entertainer for the rest
of my life and i know i will be um
because i'm so incredibly careful about
who i surround myself with um having
friends like you
uh people who are level-headed like i
know a lot of people in the comedy world
in the music world
turn to
substances and and you know vices and
stuff like that and i'm very much not
that type of person so i really am like
i'm like singularly focused on
entertaining people until i crook
so that's i'm very grateful that i'm
that type of person my parents are
nurses my mom is a nurse and my dad is a
nurse they both worked in hospitals
their whole lives my sister's a nurse my
other sister works in the hospital you
know like everybody in my family's in
medicine
and um they were very good about
raising me well uh and and not
being silly um you know so like when i
moved to l.a like
there was very little concern of me like
doing getting caught up stupid la stuff
that's good clubbing yeah and i've
literally been to clubs maybe twice in
my entire life and people think i'm a
crazy guy and like you know they
couldn't they could be like hey it's 9
p.m like you want to come meet us at
this bar no i have no i'm comfy in bed
like i'm reading on my kindle like like
leave me alone
i like that yeah all right
i think we're good i have one more
question okay yeah sure what's one thing
everyone should do in their life at
least once
hit the like button
[Music]
follow me on instagram that's what they
should do but what a bonus is to hit the
like button and subscribe for the
youtube algorithm
um
what's one thing everybody should do in
their life
i'd say learn an instrument
i was kind of baiting you into answering
that but let's see like if you can
answer it i don't think that's the
answer
some people should not ever touch an
instrument
one thing that's a diss at nickelback
dude
my freshman year of high school i was
listening to the dark horse knuckleback
album on repeat i was trying to convince
people like no this nickelback album is
really good but that's what's different
that's a byproduct of me being from
florida okay um
what's something everybody should do in
their lives i think make an attempt
to sincerely try for something you might
fail at
because some people live their whole
lives playing in the safe zone
so i think everybody just to be as vague
as possible but but everybody in their
life should make a sincere attempt at
something they're afraid to do whatever
that means for you
read the book
the war of art by stephen pressfield and
that will highlight more of what i'm
talking about so i think everybody
should read the war of art by stephen
great answer thanks so much for coming
on man nice meeting you thank you for
having me i appreciate it nice meeting
you thank you for doing this i've met
you but one time do we make out at the
end how does this work that's how we end
it yeah all right lean in
thank you guys so much but first we'll
get a free stock down below in the
description when you sign up for
public.com down below delicious
daniel check his stuff out down below
thank you so much for watching and until
next time see ya thanks folks
that was awesome thanks so much for
doing this